Brad Nessler back here on the show how
are you Brad hey buddy I'm doing fine
it's interesting it's interesting to
hear Nick Saban politic the people he
was calling rat poison all year long I
bribed I know losses losses one lakh to
do that that's what what do you think
about what you have seen you've seen
Georgia Georgia you've seen Auburn
you've seen Alabama you've seen Alabama
versus Auburn you've seen it all right
Brad you've called it all in this so if
I ought to give you the the best team in
the SEC gets to go right now
which one would you choose I would
choose Georgia but they got to be
offered I mean our burns the hottest
team right now obviously you when you
beat two number ones in a two-week span
and one of your other losses was to the
number one team now Clemson in a close
game at Clemson the other thing is just
that you know the second half they fell
apart against LSU and that was a punt
return was a difference in that game so
their two losses are you know pretty
strong I give them that and they're
playing better than just about anybody
right now the balance they have you know
Pass run and their front four on defense
is really good and they've proven that
against to number one teams in a three
week span which is pretty amazing so you
know it's it's going to play itself out
as far as Nick's comments I think if
Ohio State if Wisconsin beats Ohio State
they're in obviously I think at TCU or
Ohio State you know beat the teams that
are supposed to be there then I think
Alabama deserves a shot so you know
their one loss came against their
archrival in you know a 12-point game
after they were number one most of the
year other than the time that Georgia
had it for two weeks so I'll give you
this Alabama's first half of their
season against lesser competition they
were dominating when I had them the
first two times I'm not sure they gave
up any points I think it was a hundred
seven or something in the two games I
did and I was like wow they're rolling
but you know second half they hit
stronger teams they hit some adversity
with especially the linebacking corps
even Knicks teams that are that deep
when you get down to your eight
linebacker and you're playing
Mississippi
date or whoever it starts to show after
a while so it's interesting the way that
you just gave the scenario is that Ohio
State could be in Penn State's position
last year we have Alabama and the Ohio
State role from that where the Big Ten
champion doesn't go and a runner-up that
didn't even play in a conference
championship goes instead and you think
Alabama would would get in that way over
an Ohio State team that wins the Big Ten
championship game why um just I guess
you know I don't know what the committee
thinks and you know what I've seen Ohio
State but I haven't seen them in person
so I don't really have the eye test to
go by you know Ohio State got beat at
home pretty badly by Oklahoma
they got throttled by Iowa at Kinnick
Stadium and I just don't see where you
know I know they beaten other good teams
but I just don't see where their resume
is any better than Alabama's I just
don't see it
mm-hmm I'm not trying to be an SEC shill
here I just I've seen more of Alabama
and I you know I know when they play
well how good they are now are they
better than Ohio State that's the
committee's problem so how have you seen
Allman grow as a team then you know just
from that second half of the LSU game
when I didn't think they coached very
well and they made some mistakes
Jared Stidham has really played well I
mean he's the there's only I don't even
know if there's a handful of guys in the
SEC that are pro quarterback potential
maybe drew lock in Missouri did him at
Auburn a lot of the other guys are
college quarterbacks as far as I'm
concerned he's really come on and he's
fit into what they do you know they get
chunk plays he's got a great arm carry
on Johnson is the key I just don't know
what's going to happen there if he's
healthy then Auburn I can see why
they're favored if he's not healthy I
don't see how Georgia isn't the favorite
in the game be honest with you but
Stidham has been I think the biggest
difference for them they just you know
going back to Cam Newton they haven't
had the Cam Newton in Nick Marshall
years were a different kind of
quarterback even though Stidham you know
ran for touchdown last week and he ran
for a touchdown against Georgia the
first time he's not run first option and
there's not a lot of rpoS
their deal he just knows how to run
their system and he's doing it at a
really high level right now inside a
report behind inside a report with Brad
Nessler calling the SEC championship
game on CBS this coming weekend what you
know it's interesting we had this
conversation yesterday a lot of folks
had opinions on either side I think
there should be eight teams in because
it would it certainly would not lessen
the importance of the game that you're
calling right now or lessen the
importance of the game you called last
weekend that that all Alabama however
would be sitting back here knowing
they're in the they're in the final
eight that that's the only drawback is
it a team that could lose its last game
just chill out watch two others beat the
crap out of each other however if you
make the fact that Alabama now would
have to play a road game at the home
game of one of the top four seeds now
now they've got a lot of skin in the
game still to keep keep going for a
regular season that's undefeated where
do you stand on the subject of of these
college football playoffs Brad I would
love you know I would love to see and I
always kept saying I don't think I would
see an eighth or a more playoff team in
my broadcast career I'm gonna see it in
my lifetime am I gonna see if my
broadcast career I don't know I think
they got to play this first cycle out
you know they've set themselves up to
make sure that everybody the cities and
the bowls all get their shot at being
the big game you know this year it's a
mercedes-benz Stadium here in Atlanta I
think once the whole cycle runs through
I think they'll rethink it and you know
it's just more money and more money and
more money and and they'll get that but
I don't know that'll make it all the way
to the end of what their contract is but
I think once everybody gets the big game
they'll be more pressure to go to an 18
deal Brad have a great broadcast this
weekend thanks for calling in really
appreciate the same to you Brad Nessler
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience